y llegó el momento de hablar de revista
de prensa con rosa pérez más de un rosa
bienvenida feliz miércoles muy buen día
empezamos con colombia el espectador
como decían ayer quien dio la orden eso
es una editorial de este periódico rosa
buenos días raúl exacto hemos querido
empezar por la región y concretamente
por el país donde nos encontramos por
aquí en colombia donde el espectador se
posiciona con esta editorial claramente
a favor del movimiento nacional de
víctimas de crímenes de estado y todo
esto a raíz del vaivén judicial que se
ha desatado por estos carteles que
denuncian los casos de los 'falsos
positivos' recordemos los falsos
positivos son las llamadas ejecuciones
extrajudiciales cometidas por parte de
miembros del ejército colombiano
ejecuciones de jóvenes civiles de origen
humilde cuyos cuerpos se hicieron pasar
por los de guerrilleros y con esto los
militares los militares recibían a
cambio de recompensas condecoraciones en
el seno de las fuerzas armadas
colombianas y esto sobre todo durante
los dos mandatos
de álvaro uribe bien pues lo que sucedió
es que uno de los generales que figura
en estos carteles el general marcos
evangelista pintó denunció este
movimiento de víctimas porque por la
difusión de estos carteles entre otras
cosas señalaba que las cifras que
figuran aquí no están respaldadas por
fallos judiciales bien en una primera
instancia la justicia le dio la razón
pero ayer la corte constitucional de
colombia revocó estas primeras
sentencias y fallo a favor del
movimiento de víctimas y el espectador
claramente se posiciona con las víctimas
y dice creer que la verdad judicial es
la única que puede autorizar juicios de
valor en un país donde reina la
impunidad es fomentar la censura pues
claro que sí rosa además eso es un
derecho constitucional derecho a la
protesta y no están haciendo nada malo
pegando sus carteles pero ahora vamos
con media parte en francia- macrón en
campaña autopromoción rosa exacto de
este artículo de él en salvio una
periodista que sigue muy de cerca del
gobierno francés
pues que es muy crítica también con este
ejecutivo señala que ayer macrón en su
discurso que era tenía el pretexto
sanitario acabó haciendo pues media hora
de campaña electoral repasando los
supuestos logros de su mandato y también
comentando los programas que le quedan
que quisiera llevar a cabo antes de que
acabe el 15 nato como son el
relanzamiento de la energía nuclear o
también el refuerzo de los recursos de
la de la fuerza pública francesa y
además señala que todo esto cuando
macrón todavía no ha confirmado que se
presenta a la reelección no además la
periodista del en salvi apunta que
macrón se está presentando como
centrista y aglutinador de la sociedad
en un contexto de derechización de la
política francesa mientras que su
gobierno lleva tiempo cayendo en las
provocaciones de la extrema derecha del
país y recordemos las elecciones
presidenciales francesas el próximo 10
de abril la primera vuelta
4 en esa primera vuelta pues la segunda
y se definirá quién va a ser el próximo
presidente de francia rosa vamos a reino
unido con the gardian extinguir la
riqueza extrema la única manera de
evitar el colapso climático exacto este
esta columna de opinión de george
monbiot lo que señala es que complacer a
los grandes ricos es en cierto modo lo
que es lo que nos ha llevado a esta
situación no y que es muy clara la
correlación entre riqueza extrema y un
modo de vida completamente anti
sostenible señala un dato muy
ilustrativo que es que el 1% más rico de
la población mundial produce el 15 por
ciento de las emisiones de carbono
globales y que un estudio ha analizado
el estilo de vida de 20 multimillonarios
y ha encontrado que exactamente este
carro de vida que llevan sobre todo su
uso de los jets y de los yates privados
comporta que produzcan 3.500 veces más
emisiones de co2 de lo que deberían
producir en un mundo supuestamente
comprometido con la limitación
temperatura global de 15 grados celsius
respecto 1850 y dice que si bien es muy
difícil de imaginar el fin del
capitalismo si lo que no queremos
imaginar es el fin del mundo lo que sí
debemos imaginar es el fin de la extrema
riqueza vamos ahora con la portada del
periódico 'new yorker' el sueño
imposible
exacto esta portada ha sido muy
comentada no por esta este uso de esta
imagen universal creada por cervantes
que es la del romántico don quijote de
la mancha' que se encuentra aquí frente
a molinos eólicos no y lo que ha querido
señalar el ilustrador y el creador de
esta de este diseño drucker es que si
don quijote se encontrara en el siglo 21
se embarcaría inmediatamente en una loca
y caballeresca cruzada para salvar a su
planeta del gigante monstruo con cabeza
de hidra que es el capitalismo y
cerramos revista de prensa con el
fascinante don quijote de la mancha'
rosa gracias por toda la información
mañana nos vemos con más vista de prensa
pero ahora vamos a darle paso a nuestra
primera invitada al día
[Música]